good morning Hank it's Thanksgiving Day
2008 and I'm back where it all started
for me here at mom and dad's house in
Asheville North Carolina Hank it's just
like old times except now my face is
visible way over here thanks to sixteen
by nine technology yeah a new YouTube
thank you sure was fun hanging out with
you in the Katherine for three weeks on
the great American tour des nerdfighting
but I have to say as much as I enjoyed
the trip and playing cows and meeting
thousands of nerdfighters and watching
you become a rock star before my very
eyes
I'm also sort of grateful that our
sibling relationship has returned to you
know normal normal of course being us
communicating via video blog well
thousands of people watch it's weird
what can become normal watching hundreds
of people sing along to your brothers
songs can become normal thinking of
people you're helping in Bangladesh you
don't technically know as being people
in the same way your family as can
become normal being something called a
nerdfighter can become normal even this
view can become normal and Hank on this
Thanksgiving Day I have to say that I'm
grateful to you and to the nerdfighters
for teaching me that awesome can become
normal because that's giving me hope
that one day puff might be normal that
one day it might be normal to celebrate
intellectualism and nerd culture it
gives me hope that one day might be
normal to make sacrifices to protect the
planet we live in on in on on we live on
the planet hmm
prepositions you are always causing me
trouble is there Yeti down there Yeti it
gives me hope that one day it might be
normal to refer to your wife as a Yeti
it's funny how sometimes living in a
difficult moment in history makes you
more hopeful not less so Hank on this
Thanksgiving I'm grateful to you into
the nerdfighters for making awesome
normal oh and hey if you live in
Asheville North Carolina or nearby on
Saturday at one o'clock I'm signing at
malaprop's book store more info in the
sidebar unfortunately there won't be
like a formal presentation or reading or
anything but I will sign all your books
also your shoes potentially your
mandolins
pick I still don't know what to do with
all the widescreen like maybe I could
just have my hands up here to cover the
whole screen so at least something's
happening on the screen
maybe the hands could like talk back to
me that Thanksgiving message sucked you
should just try to be funny
oh come on I'm just you know I'm just
trying to be nice to the nerdfighters
and to Hank and to remind them how
important they are in my life and you
know what a community we're building
here and that we're gonna keep building
that sucks be funny um what do you want
me to do you want to just dance like a
monkey dance monkey but I don't that's
not fair you know like this videoblog is
not just about me dancing like a monkey
and throwing myself against the wall to
prove that I'm not an octopus story or
something that's a long bruger not an
octopus I don't I don't want oh I'm
trying to be serious today wall octopus
now all right Hank if the hands insist
Happy Thanksgiving thanks for being
awesome and I look forward to seeing you
soon all right green you gotta give it
your all it's not for you it's for
nerdfighteria I am NOT
coned Willie